elle est en travaux et ce pour cette
semaine elle Florence c'est l'autoroute
à 11 dans l'autoroute A10 pardon dans la
traversée de Tours précisément entre les
sorties Tours Centre et
Chambray-lès-Tours la circulation se
fait sur voie réduite pas simple quand
on sait 80 000 véhicules y passent
chaque jour prévu jusqu'au 20 octobre ce
chantier doit permettre l'entretien
d'ouvrage d'art Faustine Luneau
la raboteuse a déjà commencé son travail
sur cette portion de l'autoroute A10 4
km de voirie entre les échangeurs 21 et
23 qui vont être rénovés entièrement
dans le sens Bordeaux Paris en
particulier les ponts et viaduc derrière
nous on a un atelier donc de rabotage on
vient enlever l'enrobé qui permet aux
véhicules de passer et on a des peines
qui sont rentrés en action pour venir
décaper enlever la dernière couche
d'enrobée et la protection du béton qui
s'appelle une feuille d'étanchéité car
ce bitume ainsi que l'étanchéité et les
joints de chaussées vont être
entièrement renouvelés et les bétons
réparés des travaux de grande ampleur
qui vont mobiliser 15 entreprises et 250
personnes jour et nuit pendant 7
semaines
en 2019 et 2020 une première phase de
travaux avaient déjà eu lieu la portion
d'autoroute entre Tours Nord et Tours
centre avait été totalement rénové car à
tour la 17 emprunté quotidiennement par
près de 80 000 automobilistes un trafic
dense qui use les ouvrages suivant le
trafic et suivant la typologie des
ouvrages une rénovation se fait entre 30
30 et 40 ans donc là c'est des ouvrages
qui ont été construits par l'État dans
les années 70 donc on est dans les
délais pour reprendre l'entretien de ces
ouvrages des travaux qui perturbent la
circulation la sortie 22 est fermée mais
deux voies dans chaque sens sont tout de
même pu être maintenues grâce à la
suppression des bandes d'arrêts
d'urgence la réfection des autres voies
dans le sens Bordeaux Paris devrait
avoir lieu fin 2024 elle signera la fin
des travaux
afin de compenser la fermeture de la
sortie Saint-Avertin pendant les travaux
les maires de tours et de Saint-Avertin
justement réclament la gratuité de la
sortie chambray elles ont écrit en ce
sens au concessionnaire Kofi route et à
l'état